so if heroes don't heal in television
stories then why do we want to watch
them because remember in university's
story in my lectures I was talking in
movies about how he was a healing and
that change is what's compelling about
them well in television if the heroes
don't heal then why do we want to watch
them because they're gonna surprise us
with new character revelations anybody
remember that great moment in The
Sopranos when Janice and Richie who are
about to get married are having a quiet
evening at home and she's cooking him
dinner and they're both irritated but
it's just another night suddenly Janice
starts irritating Richie suddenly where
she starts irritating Janice and
suddenly Richie hits her he back answer
he's never done that before now they're
about to get married that's a big
surprise we've never seen Richie do that
before it's not a change in his
character it's a revelation because we
have a new conflict she's irritated him
and we also concede that this is gonna
be the way it's gonna be for the rest of
their marriage he's setting her up to
get hit every night and then he sits
down to have his dinner and he says what
are you gonna do cry now and he starts
eating now
Janice is about to surprise us a lot
because Janice walks out of frame when
she comes back she's got a gun he looks
at her and he sneers Janice I've got no
time for this boom and she kills him
right there now that's not Janice
healing for God's sakes or really even
changing she's just showing us a new
facet of Janice a badass that is the
critical way television heroes give us
excitement and it's why we want to watch
television not to see them heal or even
get worse gray and Grey's Anatomy wanted
to get married I think in year one when
did she get married I think you're nine
and now she's divorced again it isn't
about her healing as a character it's
about her surprising us
and in fact television is kind of more
like life than movies in this way and
it's part of what TV is so cool
television shows us surprise have you
ever known somebody for 15 years don't
they just get weirder and weirder the
better you
them finally they're so weird you can
barely take it well you're just learning
who they are
you're weird too by the way and you
don't reveal it to someone at the
beginning it's a process that's why
television story works so well and why
in a lot of ways it's a more
sophisticated form than movies so this
surprise is what we're gonna see in mr.
robot as well in Game of Thrones
surprise of eels character remember when
the Lannisters the brother and sister
are having sex at the end of that pilot
episode and suddenly a little stock boy
climbs up the tower and he sees them now
we didn't know Jamie Lannister was bad
until this moment but Jaime Lannister
goes to the window takes the stark boy
by the chest says the things I do for
love and shoves him out the window
surprise Jaime Lannister is super evil
and he's also banging his sister these
are the surprises that make us love
television because they reveal character
in such a strong way so how is this
gonna work in a movie in a television
show like mr. robot no it's gonna work
in a similar way these conflicts are
gonna be what we see Elliott our hero
and mr. robot go through now Sam Esme oh
and by the way Jenji Kohan is the
fantastic showrunner of orange is the
new black gingy is one of the most
talented television writers ever she can
handle 10 or 11 or 12 storylines in a
single episode we're gonna talk about
what storylines are because miss robot
has four to handle 12 storylines and a
single episode is a sign of a master she
can do it
very few show runners can handle that
many storylines I really love her talent
for being able to do this now
let's take a look though tonight at mr.
robot now what does mr. robot let's just
log line mr. robot does anybody know
what a log line is because a log line in
television and a log line in movies is
very different in a movie log line
you're telling the story of how someone
changes the hero in a television you're
simply showing the heroes goals and his
obstacles in the way it's a very
different long line I urge you if you're
writing to
to do what we call breaking the a story
long line over and over again because
it's literally creating your story by
asking yourself what is my story and
putting it in a frame now here's mr.
robots log line when a lonely reclusive
cyber security engineer by day and a
vigilante Hank vigilante hacker by night
hacker by night is offered a chance by
mysterious anarchist named mr. robot to
throw a wrench into the hugely powerful
financial international corporation that
runs our world the engineer struggles
with his temptation to overthrow a
system he sees as deeply unfair one that
the elite used to control 99% of
humanity now if this were a movie he
would heal this wound he would overthrow
the corporation or they would smash him
in mystery fillers which this is you can
see the villain often wins but this is
television it is the struggle that's
gonna go on for a hundred and twenty
episodes and it will make it because
this is a great hit show that makes us
want to watch mr. robot his wound which
we're gonna see will bleed in every
episode it will look like it might get
better but it doesn't
now this show is created by Sam SML and
he is the creator and one of my former
students Korra Donna has been
instrumental in creating this show from
the beginning we're really proud of core
and this show is marvelous so let's take
a look at how it actually works we're
gonna break down this story entirely so
you can understand how you can write an
hour-long drama that's like this now
this is a serial multi story structure
that simply means that you have both an
overarching goal for the season but you
also have stories that get resolved
inside the episode this is the most
popular form of television why does
structure matter so much in television
it matters because people in television
have a short attention span and you need
to give them many different story plots
because they're also arguing with their
girlfriend they're also looking at their
cell phone their dog wants to get out
and they're also in a bed that they're
uncomfortable in and they're probably
emailing somebody right all of that's
happening when you watch television it's
not true in a movie theater
you